welcome back to another day of coding
september 20th in case you're curious
all right so we're to the point where um
hopefully you know what's going on from
the previous videos because this is
basically a series at this point
code vlogs
we're at the point where we're trying to
launch our first instance of a window
and i got an error
creating the window
and it wasn't too hard to figure out
that i didn't call glfw a knit which you
have to do
before you call this
so
since we're going to launch multiple
windows we're going to potentially need
to glfw in it a lot of times
but i think you only need to do it once
okay yes i confirmed we only need to do
it once so we're probably going to do it
in this window constructor
we will just do it and we'll wrap it in
a static boolean to make sure it only
initializes once
and that should take care of it
all right so let's go ahead and do that
we'll live code this a little bit
okay so we want to go to
that's a
sample project just runs the base thing
right now
absolutely literally all it does i
commented everything else out
so that should at least get us our base
case
and we're going to look in window and
we're going to make a private static
well i guess
we need this to be hit
this boolean but we also want it to be
static
so we're going to go
i don't think we can
legally do this static
bool
glw
is it
okay so we'll put that in there
it's gonna be false
it doesn't want
it doesn't allow being initialized here
okay this is sort of a monkey wrench
because it should be
false so let's go over here
to our window and see if it allows
us to set this
it does seem to but we want to check
if it's not initialized
well we do want to initialize
and then we'll just save that
as true
now the problem here is what if this
default constructs to a true value
because it could with some compilers it
shouldn't
but it might
so maybe we just put it up here well
no there's a better way to do this
we take this
and we just put it
within the constructor function as a
local variable
here it initializes to false
now this will only get called on the
first time
the first time it's declared it's going
to set to false the rest of the time
it's only going to do this
so it shouldn't reinitialize is the
point
all right let's give that a run and make
sure we don't get a crash
probably get rid of these break points
get rid of this break point
seem to allow me to just continue let's
redo this
we should get a window popping up i
don't well i guess we're not going into
our loop
we did get something though
and this is it
so we have our console
and we have our glfw window so it does
seem to be
initially working hello
she's
it's been so long of this restructure
that
it's crazy to just be excited about
getting a window
popping up of glfw and that's something
i can do in like five minutes at any
time
but the point is we have a whole new
structure
and with this new structure we should be
able to build upon it in a way that
makes
more sense and is easier to maintain
than we were doing before
so
we're getting there
tuned because i probably got more
but uh right now i'm gonna draft up the
future plans because
that's the thing to do
you plan it out and then you code it if
you're just kind of sitting at the
screen trying to figure out what to do
next
it's generally a feels like a waste of
time it's better to go like walk around
stretch the legs get the get the blood
flowing
that sort of thing
okay and we are making some excellent
progress
the window still works great which is
ideal but now we also
we want to consider
some further things okay
oh the defaults are beautiful though
and
we want to make sure
since we support multiple windows we
want to make sure we're constructing and
destructing
them correctly and that's rather
important or else we're going to have
bugs down the road so we're making some
destructors
the instance is going to call delete on
the window
and when the window is deleted
that's going to call
the constructor over here
and the only thing i mainly need to do
is destroy this window everything else
should de-allocate
appropriately and
this shared pointer should be deleted if
nobody's using it
or this one here rather
so i put some debug statements in there
for now
because it's nice to see what's going on
uh without having to break into your
code all the time sometimes so
i just you know put them in debug
because
that's why i know some people really
don't like that but
hey if it helps with your workflow you
know they all
get stripped out with release anyway
so
i feel like it's not
too bad to just do this if you don't
want to bring it up
library anyway i'm getting ahead of
myself here's the destroy window there's
something else we need to do to consider
popping up multiple windows and that is
making the context current
for the one that's in focus
and we're going to do that with an on
window focus callback that we will set
on each of these
so since this takes the window we can
use our good friend
get window user pointer
and now we have focus on the new window
and we can
say what we want to do the main thing
we're going to need to do
is make the context current
the window we just switched to
and we're going to have to do a little
bit of magic with how our loop is
working too
is we need to consider
should we be updating all these screens
just the one that's focused on
or what but we're definitely only going
to be pulling events
from the ones focused on or rather
applying events to the one that's
focused on
but a lot of this
i guess you know
we have to decide how much control we
want to design for the end user
and while this is designed for games i
also
have a lot of other cool stuff in mind
hence the multi-window
idea coming to fruition here
all right so yeah i've got to set this
anytime we construct a new window
it should be in our default callbacks
here
so it's going to be like set
on focus callback i think
let's see if we can find it here focus
set window focus callback
pass it that
let's give it the name of this here
and there's one more really important
thing
and that is that this needs to be a
friend
of the window class
so we'll go here we'll copy this
signature
and we'll go into our window
and
we'll make another friend
and i left a comment here that should
explain why
since we are casting the gfl window to
user pointer and then accessing private
members needs to be a friend
which private members is it accessing
i guess just the window itself
wait hmm
yeah i guess it's
i'm not i'm not 100 sure
actually how to explain that but
basically
i felt like i had it all sorted out
yesterday all right
he doesn't know about this function yet
that's because it's in a cpp file
and we are declaring it as extern for
that reason
so we'll once again
copy the signature which might still be
in my
uh what should i call it but anyway
let's just put it right here
let's paste that in
and now it should know about it to be
able to set as a callback
and i think we're looking pretty good
here overall we've got a few more things
to do we need to decide
other than making the context current
what does do and design a little test so
we'll come back after a little bit and
show some more
all right little update here on how
we're going to just run these instances
so i was looking at this
and i was thinking we're going to call
run
on each individual instance why not
make it the static
public function
that basically
will do its thing
so when we call this it'll run and now
we need to
put in some kind of callback
that says we should switch to a
different instance and do all this stuff
or
we could just do them all
we could uh pass in or take this entire
list
and run all the updates on all of them
but we might want to give that kind of
control to the user
so we've got to think about some things
uh namely a lot of these poll events for
like glfw and
there's one other one i think that
um i guess mainly pull events
we probably don't need this to be per
window
maybe we can just do this in general if
any windows focused
so i've got to kind of think about that
a little bit i guess it's going to be
okay with each instance holding it for
now
but yeah that's something i'm thinking
about too here
because
we've got a we've got to really think
about oh man this is kind of making my
brain hurt at this point but with this
new run set up it still works fine
but what we're doing differently here
let me just show this
is all right there's a this is what the
public end user has access to they can
initialize instances and they can call
run and run just starts the first window
so let's go over to
here
and we can see that yeah throws if it's
empty otherwise it runs the front one
basically
and if the size is more than that we're
going to throw we'll change this later
so
we need to build in
to this callback system
some kind of switcher for the instances
so that's what i'm going to work on next
so there's a little bit of theory we can
go through here
we can say
we could go through all the instances we
could just do a for loop through these
and run this update
and as long as there's instances for it
to check and as long as they're not
closing we'll go update render pull
events
now the problem here is how does pull
events work on uncontext windows because
we're going to be calling this
a lot more than necessary so we won't
really only want to do it once
so
we've got some design decisions to sort
out here now the obvious thing that
comes to mind here
well there's two different things that
come to mind here and i don't know which
one is best or either of them are
but yeah to just do it in a loop and
isolate this pull events to just happen
uh just once and we'll have to do it in
a different
way and we'll have to design this loop
in a special instance running way
but i've got to think on that a bit
before i continue
all right we've gotten it to a point
where we have multi instances working
okay and i'll just show that here real
quick let's go ahead and hit play
and i'll i'll go through some of the
code here in a moment
and uh show you that the kind of the
theory worked it's not perfect yet of
course all right very good so we have
two windows here
and we can control them both
and do whatever we want minimize
i don't know how it's gonna okay
there we go
and we can close them
and it'll delete one close the other
and delete them both when there's none
left the whole app exits
so here's how we do it
first of all we're storing a private
list of instances well not exactly
private
we're basically going to have a list of
running instances for our whole control
system and i made an extern of poll
events
that is actually in our callbacks not
sure blogs here
and that way we can call pull events
just once and now let's take a look at
our run loop because most of the other
stuff is still the same
and we just you know put maybe we just
add to the list anytime we add a new
instance past the window the windows
options we want
so when you hit run
here's what it does
as long as there's something in the
instances it's going to keep going
through this loop
and what it's going to do is go through
every instance and as long as it's not
trying to close it's going to update and
render
and if it is trying to close we're going
to do a mark for deletion
and then after going through all those
updates we're just going to do a quick
check if anything's marked for deletion
and remove it if so and then we pull
events and keep going
so that way every window that's running
will continue to update but we're only
going to be pulling events
once rather than for everyone so that's
we pretty much hit all the marks we
wanted
uh efficiency could be a concern but
we're going to have to add in some stuff
and make it do some work before we
really know that for sure
uh
we'll probably try to do some
multi-threading where it makes sense
but that's all another ball game but for
now
we're at a pretty good stopping point
for the day i'm pretty happy
that we got several windows popping up
we could in theory make as many as we
want it should road fight so that's kind
of the beauty of this let me just go
here and let's make a whole bunch of
instances sure why not
and it should launch basically as many
as you want
there they are
and we should be able to close them
and there we go
so you could also specify what window
you want it to be on full screen or not
because you could get you a setup that
says like
you know put one window on my right
screen one window on my left and stuff
like that
but that'll be more for the developer
that's using this library to kind of
have that
set up depending on what they're doing
because i'm thinking of some kind of big
monitor app where you might have a map
up in one window
stats and graphs on another and you
might have your main
command center on your main window or
something like that and like a big
pilot type console
could be made with this not just games
that's the whole
thing
no let's just stick with three instances
for now
we're not passing any other one options
but at this point we're looking really
good i think we're done with the
windowing
next we're going to be working on
putting in some of the core
functionality into these instances and
designing a little bit of that
control
and if all goes well we should have some
opengl context very soon now as you may
have noticed i did go ahead and add
direct 3d and vulcan folders
so we are going to try to be putting
that code in there as we go as well
there's definitely going to be some time
spent reorganizing the shaders
as far as we're going to probably go to
some more binary format that vulcan can
use too we want vulcan and opengl and
direct 3d
to be able to share the same shaders as
the goal
and i think i know how to do that i just
need to spend a day or two
uh sorting it all out and implementing
it
i might be able to get it done quicker
than i think i've done it before it's
just been a while
all right well that's probably it for
this day of coding and probably this
video as we're at a decent stopping
point
[Music]
you